in all fairness I should explain to you
exactly what it is that I do
for instance tomorrow morning I'll get
up nice and early take a walk down over
to the bank and
walk in and see and uh
if you don't have my money for me I'll
crack your head wide open I
gotta tell you I've seen and heard and
been around people that have done that
you know what surprised me here is that
because she didn't hit him right on the
spot just smack him right in the mouth
smack them around a little bit but he
controlled himself pretty well you
people out of money and get away with it
hey you fat Irish prick you put my money
to sleep you go get my money or I'll put
your brain to sleep Joe Pesci without a
doubt is the most realistic the greatest
actor in a mob role ever he just lights
it up I knew guys like him so he's real
he portrays a mob guy better than any
mob guy that I knew I can tell you this
I guarantee that it's not scripted in
every way the way he says it you know he
was part of that life a little bit he
grew up in it in a way and he's got it
down pat him on a scale of one to five I
give this a five